[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Hello.
My name is Bruno Oliveira, and I
work on the Play Games team.
And we're here for a second
episode of "Play Games and
NDK." So now, we're going
to talk about how to do
achievements and leaderboards
from a native game.
So to recap from the last
episode, what we have right
now is you have your awesome
game activity, which derives
from native activity.
And then, we're implementing
it through the call backs.
And that class actually
manages the
other game helper object.
So you're just hooking up the
call backs, and then the game
helper is actually doing
the actual work.
So how do you go ahead
and unlock an
achievement from there?
So to unlock an achievement,
first of all, the call that
you want to make is
on GameClient.
Client.
You have a method that's called
unlockAchievement.
So that's the method that you
want to call and get on
GamesClient.
So normally, this is how
you would do this.
However, remember that your game
is going to be running on
a game thread that's different
from the UI thread.
So to prevent any
synchronization problems, what
we're going to do is we're going
to write a method called
postUnlockAchievement, and that
method is going to call
runOnUIThread.
And then that method is
going to invoke the
unlockAchievement method
on the UI thread.
So that's the method that we're
going to call from the
native side.
So next, since we have that
method, what we have to do is
call it from native side.
So to call it from the native
side, we're going to need the
achievement IDs.
The achievement IDs can
be obtained from
the developer console.
And they are these of funny
looking strings
that you see here.
So, these funny alphanumeric
strings.
So we're going to have one
distinct string for each
achievement that
your game has.
So once we have those, in this
case, this would be a game
where you prove theorems, and
then you advance in your
academic career.
So once you have those IDs,
all you have to do is call
unlockAchievement
for those IDs.
So first of all, you have to
initialize all the JNI stuff,
so we're going to assume that
you have that ready.
So if you don't know how to do
that, you can take a look at
the last video.
So you have your android
app structure.
You have your JNI environment.
We have the activity object
and the activity class.
After you do that, all you
have to do is just make a
simple JNI call to the
unlockAchievement method.
So we're just getting
the method ready.
Then we were allocating in Java
string that corresponds
to that achievement ID.
And then, we're making
the method call.
And remember, and this is really
important, we are also
deallocating the Java string
after we're done with it.
And that's pretty much all
there is to unlocking an
achievement.
Also, you might want to
avoid repeated calls.
Because JNI calls are
somewhat expensive.
So if you're running a tight
game loop, and you are calling
unlockAchievement all the time,
you probably want to
avoid that overhead.
So one thing that you can do is
actually keep a dictionary
on the native side that tells
you which achievement you have
you know you have unlocked, and
which ones you don't know
if you have unlocked or not.
Whenever you try to unlock an
achievement that you know you
have unlocked, you can just
return and not do anything.
So we can do that using
something like the string set
class, which is great in every
way except the fact that it
doesn't exist.
So you actually have to
implement your own string set
structure in SQL *PlusPlus
in any way that you wish.
You can use the standard
template library, or you can
use your own class.
The important thing is,
avoid making JNI
calls on every frame.
This is one of the methods
you can use to do that.
Now let's talk about
leaderboards.
So when you have leaderboards,
that's pretty much the same as
achievements, because
the method
calls are pretty similar.
So you have the postSubmitScore,
which is made
in the same way as
postUnlockAchievement.
So it's just runOnUiThread.
And instead of that, we're
posting to the UI thread.
And then on the UI thread,
we're calling
GamesClient.SubmitScore.
So that's what's actually
submitting the score.
And then from native code, we're
going to write a very
similar method as in
unlockAchievement, which
simply gets the ID of that
method, and then makes a
method called bestoftheScore
that you want to submit to the
leaderboard.
And then you call the
method, and you
delete the local reference.
And that's pretty much
all there is to it.
Now we have achievements
and leaderboards
in your native game.
So thank you very much, and
please watch our next episode,
in which we're going to talk
about how to do more
complicated stuff on
the native side.
Thank you.